sunday night at 8 eastern and pacific on
c-span's q a
the ku klux klan was established after
the civil war and reached the height of
public visibility in the 1920s
next author dale lackman discusses a
brief history of the kkk
and describes the advertising and public
relations tactics that brought clan
membership to an all-time high of
several million nationwide
mr lachman explores the topic in full in
his book for the kingdom and the power
recorded at the michigan shores club
this is about an hour
hello and welcome
my name is brendan watts and this
evening i have the honor of introducing
mr dale lachman
many of you do know him personally but
for those of you who haven't had the
pleasure in meeting him here's a little
background
mr lagman was born in iowa and raised in
western michigan from where he went on
to earn a ba in advertising from
michigan state university and an m.a in
television and film
from the university of michigan
during a 20-year career in broadcasting
working at various television stations
in the midwest until joining national
producer and syndicator tribune
entertainment company in chicago
mr lagman became an award-winning
television producer director and writer
thankfully for my sake at least he
turned to his passions of history and
writing earning a ba in history and with
a minor in education from northeastern
illinois university
he has since taught college courses in
broadcast journalism as well as middle
school world and american history where
our paths crossed
he taught me three years of history at
saint francis here in wilmette and i
know for a fact that i would not have
passed my high school history courses
without my prior knowledge from his
thorough lessons and attention to detail
this thoroughness is evidence in his
first book for the kingdom of the power
the big money swindle that spread hate
across america
chronicling the tale of two brilliant
marketing executives
who use their unparalleled knowledge to
promote the ku klux klan throughout
america
remarkably a previously untrue untold
true story praise for the book has been
flowing in since its release
mark potok of this southern poverty law
center calls it a detailed account rich
with fascinating characters stating dale
lagman shows how the group's exponential
growth was driven almost entirely by an
unlikely pair of public relations
experts who turned out to be consummate
swindlers
while arne bernstein author of swastika
nation stated filled with unexpected
twists and characters you only wish were
fictional coupled with expert research
lagman skillfully tells an original and
riveting tale how the accounts in the
book are all shockingly true i have no
idea
what i do know however is that i would
not be surprised to see mr lightman's
work turn into a hollywood film one day
so let me introduce the man you're all
here to see mr dale eggman
[Applause]
thank you brendan it was a pleasant
surprise when i heard that he was going
to introduce me he's a wonderful student
i had lots of wonderful students when i
taught here
thank you to michigan shores for
inviting me thank you to monique who
especially who thought of of bringing me
here
it's a pleasure it's a pleasure to be
here tonight
as a teacher
i used to like to talk about
or try to bring young people middle-aged
school kids
into stories in a more relevant fashion
so i remember at one time i talked about
a time machine now kids love that
and i talked about um us all getting our
lawn chairs and coming out uh to gilson
or we could right out of the window of
this club
and set the machine for 1673 and just
wait until we saw canoes coming from the
south to the north
and they would have been black robed and
they would have been marquette and
joliet coming past on their way back
from their exploration of the
mississippi
they left from saint ignac michigan and
entered the mississippi from around
green bay they found the river there and
on the way back
after they decided after going south for
a long time they weren't finding the
northwest passage
that um
they found the portage at chicago and
then came up the lake and of course in a
canoe you'd be very close to
the shore so you probably could have
seen those two as you came by
i want to use that that same concept of
the time machine
briefly to um to introduce this book you
know brendan told you some good things
about it
but i would use that same time machine
and we could lift up these chairs and
take them
over to rand old rand road leading up to
lake zurich coming out of chicago
and the date would have been august 16
1921
and it was night and we would have been
sitting there and then we would have
seen lights coming from chicago
and we'd have seen 2 000 automobiles
pass by with their headlights on
people said
that it took over two hours for this
procession to get past them
and they headed up to
a farm
just in between lake zurich and
barrington
and
they formed
a circle with over half a mile diameter
of the automobiles with their headlights
going in on the circle they made
bonfires and altars
and
10 000 hooded men
came out of those cars
and 2300 other hooded men blindfolded
came out as well
what this was was a giant initiation
ceremony of 2300
new klansmen
on that night in 1921
and
pretty spectacular uh show that night
there were some journalists who covered
it in fact there were supposed to be
some white journalists
who were going to go but had to be
blindfolded so they wouldn't know the
location of this farm they got lost
they didn't get there until later we
know a lot about the ceremony because
two black reporters from the chicago
defender put on hoods and actually got
initiated that night and covered the
event
it's pretty spectacular the other really
interesting part about this story is the
location
it was a farm it was a horse farm
and the owner is somebody we may know
about
his name was charlie wigman
any sports historians in the audience
want to put your hand up who charlie
weekman was
it's the 100th anniversary of wrigley
field
which was called weekman park right
um he
he had a failed
pro team uh in a different league
and then he bought the cubs and he built
wrigley field
sold it i think in 1921 to the wrigley
family
that was his farm that night we don't
know if
he was actually a clan member very very
well have been a clan sympathizer and
allowed them to use that location
now to bring it really close to us here
around this club
is that the article that i've read says
that that location was unknown to almost
everyone but a few clan leaders and in
fact the imperial wizard from atlanta
was there that night william joseph
simmons will talk about a lot
but it says that the clans in evanston
and at northwestern university assumed
it was going to be in a field west of
evanston
i'll help you know also from a book i've
read by name my name kenneth jackson he
claims that there was a clan and we'll
met as well
so 1921
most of us
would probably assume that the klan is
an anti-black southern
organization
as you can tell a bit by that not
necessarily
and that's a lot about what this book
covers i want to show you
or talk to you about
um some of the the facts that i did some
research on
by 1923 there were 35 000 klansmen in
oregon
35 000.
vermont had five to ten thousand montana
thousand kansas forty thousand
oklahoma had uh two thousand in tulsa
and twenty five hundred in oklahoma city
ohio seventy thousand attended a state
clone vacation you know a meeting
uh in massachusetts there were twenty
thousand at a rally in worcester
so
um
they were not just in the south i have a
couple i'm from michigan so i have a
couple of articles from the grand rapids
press
one of them shows in
1925 on july the 4th
3 000 ku klux klan members from around
michigan marching through the main
street of grand rapids michigan
now if you're ever in grand rapids
michigan that'd be one of the last
places you'd assume the clan was
even a bigger rally
happened
in jackson michigan
i'll try to get the date here july the
4th 1924
they held an enormous uh
gathering of plants from all over the
state of michigan and there were 100 000
and there's a picture
of them
kind of gently
and um i want to read a little something
the one photo of many you have probably
seen in your history books when you were
growing up or in your kids history books
in high school or in junior high
are the pictures of the klan marching
down pennsylvania avenue in washington
d.c it's the one picture you see often
see
well h.l menken was there that day a
reporter for the baltimore sun very
famous man
and this is what
he said
uh i have this quote coming up but i'm
saying the most searing images of this
time are photos of over 60 000 rogue
clansmen parading down pennsylvania
avenue in washington dc on august 8th
1925.
fame news famed newspaperman h.l menken
was there to observe
yeah this is this quote from the paper
the parade was grander and gaudier by
far than anything the wizard had
prophesied it was larger it was thicker
it was higher in tone i stood in front
of the treasury building for two hours
watching the legions pass
they marched in lines of 18 to 20
solidly shoulder to shoulder
i retired for refreshment and was gone
an hour and when i got back to
pennsylvania avenue it was still a
massive white from the treasury building
to the foot of the capitol hill a full
mile of klansmen
so
also when i taught and brendan may
remember this across
the the white board behind me when i
taught all the way across the room i had
in large letters history dot dot dot it
gets old after a while
and i probably did that for my own
amusement and probably for some parents
during parent-teacher
conferences i'm not sure the kids really
got the joke
but actually um history never gets old
when you find
a really new fascinating and really
untold story
uh to me that
you know makes a very exciting history
first i want to talk about for a lot of
you the history of the cuckoo's clan
i'm surprised a number of people think
it started in indiana
well
actually
it started uh in reconstruction post
civil war in tennessee
pulaski tennessee i believe
and the story is that there were uh
eight
uh former confederate officers who were
kind of bored out of their mind because
the war was over now so it's just quite
exciting to be in a war and now it
wasn't
most of them were college men and some
of them were in fraternities so
they decided to uh use the greek word
for circle which is kuklos
and they uh called it a clan c-l-a-n
later on they just decided for
alliterative purposes to make that a k
as well so kuklos clan
was the original part of this
somewhat for amusement they would like
to they would put on the white sheets
and they would scare former slaves who
were very superstitious
and they were claiming that they were
the ghosts of confederate dead
and they had great fun doing this
um
what happened is that changed all of
this
was
a policy in reconstruction south the
radical republicans got much firmer with
the south
they wanted to protect the rights given
to blacks to vote and and do things like
that
so they they made a military districts
and they sent the us army to really
control the south
and south blacks were beginning to elect
officials i think there's even a black
senator in washington during this period
of time
and uh this caused the members of the
klan to change into
what was kind of a
inconsequential group into a very
violent group
um
and i can read a little bit about that
as well as they begin uh actually if uh
i believe in forrest gump don't they
name force after nathan bedford forrest
who was the confederate general who
became the first clan
imperial wizard
okay
here is something from a book called the
history of the klan
and its activities in america
murders were common floggings even more
so one victim was left crippled after he
received 900 lashes on a midnight raid
alabama congress documented
109 murders committed by grand dragon
john morgan's knights
and that number was no doubt
conservative clans burned greene
county's courthouse
followed shortly by three schools for
blacks in utah
uh georgia clan riders killed four
blacks wounded 50 in october of 1870
georgia was worse under grand dragon and
later governor and u.s senator john
gordon
in a three-month period from august
to october 1868 klansmen killed 31
persons shot 43 more stabbed five
whipped at least 55 including eight
floggings of 300 to 500 lashes apiece
they became extremely violent and
because of that
president grant sent the seventh cavalry
down to really uh put down the klan they
passed a law in congress that made them
a terrorist group essentially
uh and which gave them the right to kind
of take care of them
uh interestingly george armstrong custer
was there as part of the seventh cavalry
for a brief time until he moved out west
and we know what happened to him out
there
so um
the clan effectively went away which was
okay at that point because once
reconstruction and the army left the
south reverted to the way it was before
the civil war
essentially and uh
jim crow laws were passed you know
extremely unfair laws
um
and that system of sharecropping which
was essentially like slavery because the
economically they kept blacks unable to
ever gain any money or to to get out of
that system
so we move ahead now to the second clan
the modern ku klux klan which is the one
uh i've written about
and that
was 1915
not in indianapolis but in atlanta
georgia and on thanksgiving night of
1915
a man named william joseph simmons
initiated the new clan atop stone
mountain georgia
with a fiery cross and all of that
he coincided this with um the debut in
atlanta of birth of a nation if you're
familiar with the tremendous film by dw
griffith i say tremendous i'm a film
major
because he was a brilliant filmmaker who
did things no one had ever done he just
shows a pretty bad story to do it with
it was based on a play called the
klansmen
and it glorified the clan in the
reconstruction south
and
became it was the highest budget film
ever made at that point the longest film
ever make to that point and it made an
enormous amount of money over years
because they just kept er you know
running it over and over and over and
over again
in fact
nine days after
the thanksgiving day it debuted at a
theater in atlanta and people were very
emotionally
um
taken up by the film because even the
filmmaking process that he used got
people very excited because it had never
been done before
and when the people excitedly ran out on
the street simmons had a bunch of of his
new klansmen in full ropes on horseback
firing guns under the air
so it must have been quite a scene
so
that's not the story here because
simmons clan doesn't do very well he's a
brilliant orator he's a former minister
great speaker terrible organizer
four years later by 1919 there were only
two or two to three thousand members of
the clan they were all in alabama and in
georgia
and he was broke he was mortgaging his
house they were badly organized
and quite frankly uh in a few more
months the clan really would be dead
now after i say all of that the first
line of my book is this is not a clan
book
so i guess i've just wasted all this
stuff
it's really a book about early 20th
century marketing pr and
journalism that was uh all these
industries were very much in their
formative stage at that point
and it's a unique new history
because a lot of this has never been
written before
and when i over the years when i said oh
you're writing a book what's it about i
would always have to say it in a few
sentences and i've still yet to find a
person that's ever heard this story
which is a good thing i think once we
can get more people to know about it
um
it's really it's a story about two
people and i think history's uh
fascinating when it involves people you
know if you're just talking about dates
when things were signed and
all that
that's pretty dry but people are into
you know are unbelievably ultimately
interesting people and the two people
here
are edward young clark
and elizabeth bessie tyler
they were the owners of
an advertising and pr firm in atlanta
they're quite different people edward uh
was actually the son of a former owner
of the atlanta constitution newspaper
and he worked as a religion editor for a
while
his brother actually was the editor for
about 40 years of that paper
but
he was essentially a con man and and he
didn't didn't want to run the straight
course elizabeth uh bessie as she was
known
was born dirt poor on a farm outside of
atlanta
and
had quite a difficult life very very
little education at all
was pregnant at 15 married uh like a day
before her 16th birthday and and gave
birth to her daughter a couple days
later
that was the first of four marriages for
her
and
she was however a brilliant woman she
was one of these people that didn't need
to be educated she really was a very
resourceful person
they were
in this early time of public relations
their agency dealt with a lot of
non-for-profits they did campaigns for
the red cross and salvation army and
people like that
their biggest
client was the anti-saloon league has
anybody ever heard of that
and i i went to a talk with ken burns
did at the union club downtown a couple
years ago when he was debuting
his prohibition special
series on wttw
he called
the anti-saloon league one of the
largest single-issue lobby groups in the
history of the united states
obviously they were trying to get
prohibition passed they were brilliant
also they had an enormous facility in
westerville ohio
with printing presses that sent out so
much mail around the country is
unbelievable
and their representatives in atlanta was
the southern publicity association and
edward and bessie
i think they probably learned some
things from them along the way
but of course the worst thing that could
happen in edward and bessie was what
the passage of the volstead act so
suddenly there was no need for the
anti-saloon league anymore they lost
their largest client
this is about the same time that um
simmons and his clan was about to go
under
so timing i think is really everything
in history
these two met
actually bessie bessie's son-in-law
uh worked for
her agency and he looked at a little
hand-drawn ad that simmons has put in
the atlanta constitution or journal with
his last money
and he was a joiner of things and he
said i like that uniform that's kind of
cool
and he he went to some meetings joined
the clan and he actually came back to
edward and bessie and said you know what
we know how to do this we can help them
and they decided to take a chance edward
joined the clan to do some research
and they finally
went to simmons and signed a contract
with him
to mount a
membership
campaign
and
it was a very lucrative camp uh contract
i don't think simmons had a lot of
choice in the matter because he was
going under
so they got 80
of of every initiation fee that they
could bring in
and
it's pretty good pretty good
and they um
they set up this national network they
cut the entire united states up now
first that's also interesting right away
because you think the klan is not
anything but southern regional these
people thought really big
they cut the entire united states up
into nine domains they put a grand
something
exactly you have to read my book
uh over each domain
within each domain were a number of
states and a head of that was put there
and then they sent out guys named clegal
kligels
because everything in the clan has a k
start on it
and they would go
everywhere and
sign up people for the klan
they were
wildly successful
in places like oregon
interesting
again timing is everything
we're talking post world war one america
this story may not have happened five
years earlier may not have happened five
years later i think in history a lot of
times that happens
the situation was perfect
post world war one america was a powder
keg really ready to explode
a couple of things had happened the
great migration is one if you've heard
of that it was this tremendous movement
of people from the south blacks from the
south to the north
there was a best-selling book a couple
years ago called warmth of another sun
and it talks it was not any kind of
organism organizing at all people just
started packing up and what they did is
the north had
possibility of better paying jobs
and the north had a possibility of
better housing it still wasn't good but
it was better than the south
and the way they got there was railroads
and they would take
railroads that
went south to north and terminated in a
city in chicago it was illinois central
from new orleans to
to chicago
and normally when they got to a city
that's where the jobs were and that's
where they settled
and the blacks in chicago for example
settled in the south side
so we had a lot of blacks coming north
looking for jobs
um we also had
a time
when a lot of american men were
in the army in world war one so often
blacks were getting the jobs that they
had the union
movement was quite sympathetic to blacks
actually
so they're actually doing well
the soldiers come back looking for the
jobs and there's a real conflict here
also you get a recession after war
normally because of retooling for peace
time
so there was a jobs crisis you also had
a huge number of immigrants now because
all during world war one from 1914 to
1918 there are no immigrants coming
because
the atlantic is there in the submarine
submarines out there so
with the war over you get a flow of of
immigrants also needing jobs also
needing houses all of this
um
and
we're we're going to be talking about
white protestants because that's the
majority of america most of the people
coming were
non-english speakers
and non-protestants they were like most
catholics you had jews from eastern
europe and russia
you also had a very scary thing even
today and that's when you say the word
socialist
um because of the the revolution in in
russia in 1917 you had people who were
considered to be social so it was a red
scare also
all of these things were happening
and there's an interesting thing here i
didn't know a lot about until i wrote
this book it's called the red summer of
1919.
you may have heard of that maybe not
all of this was happening um
and there were that year over 30 major
race riots all across the united states
in every part of the united states not
just localized in the south or is
everywhere
the most famous one that you may have
heard about happened in chicago
although it wasn't necessarily the
largest one
um
if you've noticed the chicago tribune
does these flashbacks every year where
they go back in their archives
this is uh the one about the incident in
chicago which happened in 1919
there
were segregated beaches in chicago and
on this beach which i think is around 29
29 street beach
it was a very hot july day
blacks were on their sideways around
their side
a young boy drifted now i don't know if
he was swimming or he's on a raft i've
heard both
a black boy into the white area and
white started throwing rocks and things
at him they hit him and he drowned
there's a confrontation on the beach
between whites and blacks
the police came and instead of
arresting the whites who had done it
they were arresting the blacks
and what happened was about five days of
riots across chicago where hundreds of
people were injured about 30 or 40
killed
and thousands
left homeless after this this happened
in washington dc it happened in tulsa
oklahoma it happened everywhere during
this red summer
you can imagine this scared the white
protestants as well so
when you take all of these things
into account
you get
a perfect
marketing plan for edward and bessie for
blacks
who are now in parts of the north
but they expanded it i mean they were
greedy
and and believe me they took this job on
not because they were clan members or
sympathizers they took it on purely for
money
and if you read my book
they also started cheating their own
client they were double dipping all over
the place
and making enormous amounts of money
but they decided uh to send their people
to any town in america and find out what
that town was afraid of
oregon
probably asians right significant
japanese and chinese population on the
pacific coast
new york city could have been jews it
could have been union organizers because
they didn't really like unions
could have been socialists
and everywhere catholics
you know i chronicle in my book uh a
really very bloody and violent
anti-catholic history in america since
the 1600s all the way you know into the
20th century
so um i want to read a little something
here
as well about this
that's what a historian said about this
period of time
bessie and edward knew their marketplace
and fashioned a product guaranteed to
sell
historian nancy mclean summed up the
situation planned leaders constructed a
new kind of reactionary populist
politics that yoked white supremacy to
100
americanism anti-semitism anti-communism
hostility to immigrants antipathy to
liberals and support for old-time
protestant religion
things were changing and white
protestant america was fearful the
status quo was in jeopardy fear can be
an easy sell
it was indeed fertile ground bessie and
edward
would had tapped into a huge and
receptive marketplace of fearful white
protestants business was good
okay
now
bessie and edward were making enormous
fortunes
in fact
the most glaring fact that eventually
i'll talk about this
edward and bessie are forced to leave
and they're forced out
bessie left for california with
reportedly 800 thousand dollars in cash
which i use an inflation calculator is
close to 10 million dollars
she built an enormous antebellum home
that looks like tara
and it's still in
it's still in atlanta it's still
occupied by people it's on the national
um register of historic places
so the the the little dirt poor girl uh
was doing quite well
everything
was eventually exposed by the new york
world newspaper
the new york world is the one that was
founded by joseph pulitzer
and he's the man i talk about the
history of that as well the man pretty
much invented the modern newspaper
and
they went after the clan
for 25 straight days of a full front
page coverage
they had sent the reporters all around
the country
and eventually won the first pulitzer
prize and investigative journalism for
it
so some fascinating characters on the
journalism side in this the story as
well
as a result of that hearings were held
in congress simmons was put on the stand
in under the rules committee of congress
which is pretty fascinating reading
and um
eventually
things get exposed one of the biggest
problems for edward and bessie is that
they had an affair
and were were found in a brothel that
bessie owned
partially clothed with alcohol in 1919
and by his wife
and a police officer
in 1919 that story got buried a bit but
in 1921 when the world started searching
everywhere they found that story and it
uh appeared nationally because the the
new york world syndicated it in about 12
other papers as well
it was really the beginning of the end
for them uh klansmen still believe they
were kind of christian protestants and
they didn't vote so well they also
started finding out that bessie actually
was running the clan and there were no
women in the clan
and that wasn't very popular so
there was a palace coup of sorts simmons
got overthrown by another grand wizard
and and edward and bessie
lost it all and and had to get out of
town
um
the
momentum that they had caused however
this was about 1923
was kept the mechanism was kept in in
place and
the number uh the shocking number of
what they did was that the eventual
membership of the clan reached nearly 5
million
and this appointment was 100 million
people in america
and when you um
you find out who's eligible
at that point that would be uh white
protestant men who were native born that
was another thing
immigrants they did not want
so when you do some math
you find out that about between one out
of three and one out of two of all
eligible men in america remember the
plan
in 1925.
so
the story a lot of this has to do with
how people can affect history these
people change the face of america in in
all the wrong ways
uh another thing is that they were
brilliant people who really used the
gift that they had in in all the wrong
ways
um
so
it's a fascinating story they are
fascinating characters they're not nice
characters they're not good characters
but they are
incredibly fascinating the story is very
rich in a lot of the characters that are
in it
with that
there's a lot more detail in the book
that i can't tell you right now in the
time that i have but i'd love to take
any questions that you might have
um and the one thing i was asked to do
because we are actually recording this
for um c-span 3 history television is
that you just wait until the boom mic
gets over to you and they can pick up
the questions so if you'll hold one
moment
what was the catholic church's position
as a clan was
going through this
growth period
you made many references to
protestantism and
of society to the catholic church
i'm not sure there was an official
stance out of the vatican
american bishops and cardinals were
obviously against the klan they didn't
have a lot of ability to to stop
anything at that point because they were
a significant minority compared to
the protestant majority
thank you anyone else
what is the status of the klan today
at this moment how are they doing are
they thriving are they
underground are they appreciated are
they you know demonized what are they
doing
well uh they've been a couple of timely
things uh in the in the news about a
year ago in orland park
illinois they um people found on their
driveways plastic baggies um
with like a piece of a rock i think in
it that would hold it in a flyer in a
paper flyer to join the
clan a couple of months ago in the
hamptons in new york same thing only
they used candy to wait to wait down the
plastic bag
but
the clan that i was i'm talking about
was centrally organized
out of atlanta with one man running the
whole thing the imperial wizard
and the clan is nowhere near that now
the klan fell off rapidly after 1925.
it did spike again during the civil
rights movement you know when you see a
few documentaries about freedom riders
and things like that you see a lot of
klansmen around
but right now the southern poverty law
center who brendan quoted on the back of
the book estimates about 5 000
nationally
and even that's not a big number because
they're all small clans of maybe 20
people they're spread all around the
country but they don't talk to each
other there's no centrally located so
they're really not a tremendous threat
you know they have all the civil rights
anybody else has as long as they don't
break any laws they can get a parade
permit and they could parade they could
parade down wilmette or chicago streets
as long as you don't break a law
but that's about the status of it right
now
if you go to the southern poverty law
center's website they have something
called clan watch which is a map of the
united states you click on certain
states and they'll
identify the names of of the groups but
they're around but they're
probably smaller than some of the other
skinhead hate groups you know some of
those they're among that whole mix
just a personal note my family is from
clinton indiana which is in southern
indiana in the 20s they were catholic
and they had crosses burned on their
lawn at that time right
indiana was probably the most violent
and most clan infested state they
actually controlled state government
the governor most of the legislature
you may ask why the klan dropped off
i'll tell you one of the reasons was is
d.c stevenson who was the leader of that
plan
very powerful nationally as well as in
indiana and
he
took a woman
across state lines and raped her and
beat her savagely
and then dropped her off at her parents
house
and she was so distraught that she
committed suicide he was
tried and sent
to prison for life imprisonment
he actually thought that he would get
pardoned by the governor that he put in
place the clan governor and he didn't
got quite angry and exposed a whole lot
of things from jail
there were other financial scandals as
well and that's a lot of it would cause
the klan membership to drop
the leo frank
case in atlanta was that uh around the
same time as
this rise of the klan in atlanta the leo
frank story's in my book
that happened uh in the year prior to
the 1915 start of the new clan
uh it's a story of a um
of a 14 year old girl who worked in a
pencil factory
in atlanta and she looked marietta she
took the trolley in one day to pick up
her paycheck and she was never you know
she was later found in the middle of the
night
raped and murdered in the pencil factory
somebody implicated leo frank who was a
northern jew
and superintendent of the factory
and he didn't do it but
he was found guilty
and was going to be executed the
governor gave him a stay it was a very
unpopular decision for that governor
he was put in a prison camp in
millageville georgia and a bunch of
people from marietta drove all the way
across the state in the middle of the
night took him out of the prison drove
all the way back to marietta and hung
him on a tree
and the story was all the people
marietta came out and had kind of a
party around his dead body
it kind of talked about some of the
hatred in the south especially for the
north for jews and all of that and and a
number of those men who had done that
were among those first people on stone
mountain who became the first clans
people so it's
so yes the leo frank story is involved
i'm curious who was that governor of
indiana that the clan put in place
uh this is actually governor georgia oh
the governor under uh stevenson i don't
know the name of the man
but it would have been in about 1925.
another personal story my mother went to
st mary's notre dame at that time and
they came on the campus of notre dame
and st mary's notre dame and the nuns
made all the girls at st mary's notre
dame go down in a basement area they
were afraid for their lives and they
they had to stay there for several hours
while they were these crosses were being
burned on the campus of you know st
mary's in notre dame but she talked
about it many times there's a book i've
not read it yet there's a book called i
think notre dame versus the clan
oh really
and i think it's in some of the area
libraries
what are the major years
that your book covers
1920
well the major years i i mean it begins
in 1915 with the formation of the klan
but it skips to like 1920 that and and
goes to about 1925.
really deals with bessie and edward's
involvement
well in regard to that what kind of
marketing did bessie and her partner
give the clan that made the membership
increase so much what were their
techniques
well a lot of it had to do with the
training of their sales people
and the organization of those sales
people
one thing i didn't mention this is the
golden age of fraternalism
this period of time in america
there are more
fraternal society memberships at any
time a lot of people belong to four or
five six of them at a time
and a lot of them had
secret paraphernalia
you think about the masons but there are
lots of others that have rituals and
costumes and secret meetings and all of
these things that the klan as well had
so it was easily acceptable by a lot of
these people who were fraternalists
and they used a lot of their sales
people were former fraternal organizers
as well so they really knew how to do
that
um from a pr standpoint it's like a
primer for doing pr
um
you know it's it's all the things that
they did it's damage control it's
newsletters and its press releases its
lecturers it's they did all kinds of
things pretty sophisticated
hey dale to your point about
fraternalism were there any major
crossovers with the klan
like were the masons doing a lot of
recruiting or were there was there an
organization in the northwest
well
there was a lot of recruiting because
it was the hot time for being a part of
a fraternal society
um there's an interesting one that that
simmons worked for edward worked for and
a couple of other characters they worked
for the woodmen of the world
have you ever heard of that
if you've been in omaha there's a
skyscraper called the woodman building
it still exists as an insurance company
a lot of fraternal societies were secret
in nature and many of them offered
insurance for their
members it was one of the reasons you'd
get involved a lot of immigrant
societies the polish alliance and others
the sons of italy people would come
from they would congregate with like
people of theirs and they would get
benefits uh like insurance women in the
world was just as secret as the clan and
in a way
just as um kind of bizarre i've seen
some of the pictures of their costumes
they they would have like a tree stump
and an axe was their big thing
um for many years when a woodman of the
world died he would have a gravestone
that looked like a tree stump
but that's how they learned from those
organizations and they just transferred
it right into recruiting for the klan as
well
i wonder do you have a topic for your
next book yet
i have a thought
i have a thought
it's early 20th century it's actually
involving the it probably would be the
philippines insurrection which is a war
almost no one knows anything about
making our microphone man work
what was the relationship between the
organized crime and the gangsters of the
1920s and the clan were they in
competition or in collusion
i'm not aware of a connection at all
i've not heard of one
did the klan have any success in the
military
i've not heard anything but obviously a
lot of guys in the military were
klansmen
throughout american history southerners
and others
but i'm not sure
there's there's an incident in the book
where
a man who was a world war one aviator
wants the klan to help him put together
an aviation arm of pilots for the clan
so
edward and bessie were very interested
in finding out all the names and
addresses of military guys how to
recruit them
how many hours of research do you have
to do put into this to create this book
i mean how long how many years have you
been working on this how many hours per
day
because this is that's a hard one that's
a really hard one to put a number on um
i will tell you that researching is far
easier now than it was a few years ago
with the internet
also if you've got a cell phone with no
long distance
charges on it because often i would read
about a certain part of the country and
i would just look up the local library
and call the research librarian
and they would do a lot of work for me
sometimes because i think they're just
waiting for the phone to ring and you
would get old newspaper archives from
the area about the people
one of my
greatest discoveries in this book was uh
one of the characters
on the journalist side
had gone to the virginia military
institute and i called the archivist
there and got supplied um from deep in
their files his entire biography that he
himself had written and there are things
in there that have never been
this this particular man was written
maybe in a sentence in most books
and it turns out he was much much more
from that material so that was a one of
those moments of the aha moment you know
that's pretty pretty cool there's also
the son-in-law j.q jett who brought the
clan to betsy and edward
there are jq jet papers in the
university of georgia rare manuscript
library that i'm sure have never been
looked at
and i looked at them and it's pretty
interesting
so
you also can find an awful lot of
documents now that are scanned and
online
very old old documents
how did you hear about this story
when i left the television business and
wanted to become a history teacher i
took
majored in history at northeastern
illinois and i was at a ethnic history
course
and the professor would
talk in each lecture about a different
ethnic group coming to america you know
italy one time germany pulled when he
did the african-american one and he got
to the point this point in history
he i take good notes and tell all your
kids to take good notes and listen and
not fall asleep
um
he said that there was this man and
woman
who helped recruit members for the klan
their names were this and this and he
had the names were switched
but uh he said that uh and they also had
an affair and i thought
sounds kind of interesting
and uh actually i wrote as a screen i
wrote it as a screenplay first because i
thought all the elements of a screenplay
and that that's what i did for a while
and then somebody told me it would make
a great book so i switched gears
apropos your last comment about the
divisions there's a book the american
nations that details the
divisions racial ethnic religious and so
forth and the violence that attends
those divisions
right from our founding
you'd be surprised what i quote a couple
of founding fathers and on their
opinions of catholics actually that are
quite interesting
um
actually there's a good book called
ethnic chicago which talks about all of
these things yes
okay thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you